you come an audition for some movie
indeed what did you know about prints
beforehand what do you know about this
movie well I still have the Rolling
Stone cover of prints and vanity as a
starving actor that was my motivation
inspiration I bought the magazine I said
I want to be special like them one day
busting my ass auditioning my one of my
first agents is here tonight Judith
Fontaine who kept this fight for two
Latin not the girl next door woman busy
all the time doing commercials but I get
an audition I was the last person they
saw mm she was the last person on the
tape we sent in to to print so I said oh
I know why you put it last because she
was definitely the best you wanted and
set it up so I would pick I didn't know
that yeah Wow were you very clear and or
what happened was um once vanity vanity
left to show because she had gotten
offered by Martin Scorsese to be in The
Passion of the Christ and she was on it
at a crossroads at the time and she
decided to go there and so we were left
without an actress I guess about maybe
four weeks before shooting yeah so we
went on a completely national platform
at that time trying to find vanity now
here's the interesting thing I flew to
various states to meet with whoever was
auditioning and they were all trying to
be like vanity they all came in looking
like vanity they acted like vanity and
it wasn't all that interesting we had
the real person she left and now these
people are kind of coming in it was
fantastic about Apollonia is that she
came in from the gym or something you
were wearing sweats in a sweatshirt and
she was just she just came in and she
was extremely sweet about just I'm just
here and we spoke for a while
and then I like her right away and
that's when I called Prince and I said
I'd like you to meet her and see if she
can work with her and let's see what
happened so he came by and you can tell
what happened then
well I went to the audition and
introdution
I auditioned first year in Los Angeles
good right in our office right so I walk
into an office we videoed you that's
right and we sent it back to Albert but
you I don't see it I walk into this out
this office and Nia Peeples had just
walked out and she was really terrified
she's like oh ha and I was like okay she
is you you you're the one you're the one
and I thought we did that to you yeah
Wow and she kind of scared me but I
thought nah she's trying to throw me off
actors right ha ha that's what they do
in Hollywood we audition exactly I
walked in there and I gave him a tape
and you know resume and bio and I had
some little musical tape some cheesy
thing many asked me to take my shoes off
so I thought oh wow they're into feet so
I took my shoes off they wanted to see
you know my size and I went back home my
agent calls me because you're they're
flying you to Minnesota I arrived and
I'm at the Holiday Inn I meet chick
wonderful chick is a security detail and
they picked me up and Prince takes me
out for a ride in a purple limo I was
wearing a Flashdance sweatshirt ripped
up and I was wearing these white pedal
pushers at the scene was already you
could see my skin you know broke actor
and I kept putting my hands on top so
Prince wouldn't see that you could see
they were ripped up pants but that was
the best that I had so he drives around
this the country and I roll down the
window and I just stick my head out and
I said look there's cows and it's so
green and the sky is so blue so at that
point I think my you know my tuchus is
in his face uh he took me out to eat
he had spaghetti
and they took me back to the hotel and
then they pick me up in the evening for
the audition which was at First Avenue
and at that time I thought First Avenue
was a very famous street you're gonna
take me to the Avenue
you know like Fifth Avenue and so this
is no no it's a nightclub so I wore a
black spandex time where my metal you
know mesh
I think I'd saved up for six months and
starved to buy that blouse and we go to
First Avenue and it's the dance audition
see how I respond to people first class
you know all this stuff and it was great
we had a wonderful time I remember we
walked in it was like Moses had walked
in because we walked into the dance
floor and everybody just parted and
that's when I was I thought this is
really quite impressive these I had the
1999 tape I knew this new wave black guy
that were purple and lipstick you know
an eyeliner I had all of his music and
he was great so they dropped me off I'm
sorry how different was he from what you
imagined he would be from listening to
the tapes and looking at the alcohol
completely day and night he was very
very reserved he was very shy very quiet
so I had to do all the talking which is
you know I'm like Chatty Cathy a little
and they dropped me off all of a sudden
somebody knocks at my door at the hotel
room and ready to fly out the next day
and it was chick he says a kid likes you
let's play cool
and I said I would really like him a lot
to thank you and I gave a big hug and a
kiss
they fly me back to LA when I got there
they said you've been cast so I started
crying and I called everybody that I
knew all seven people